[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the Stars have been posting
online
Ellen DeGeneres isn't waiting any longer
she took to Twitter to hilariously
announce she wants to join
fifth harmony after kamila Kibeho exit
from the group posting this amazing pic
of herself photoshopped into a group
shot of the girls wearing a matching red
jumpsuit writing looks like it's just us
now
the girls seem to be loving the idea
they jokingly responded with you and
your tracksuit are late for rehearsals
where you at girl even Camilla got in on
the action
tweeting man replaced so soon but
admitted Ellen had always been a better
dancer
speaking of dancers Dancing with the
Stars champ Lorie Hernandez got a
surprise while on tour with the show her
fellow Olympian Simone biles Simone
posted some adorable pics of the two
along with her calf mates another
dancing champ bindi Irwin shared this
adorable video to Instagram of her
boyfriend Chandler Powell trying his
first lychee while the two enjoyed a
dinner picnic together in Australia day
5 Dave gave me fake a 5/5 meanwhile
Nicole Richie and Kate Hudson are
keeping their New Year's resolution of
getting their fitness back on track even
if they are a little behind
Kate shared a pic of her and her gal
pals to the gram after a hike in LA
joking in the caption we had no fun at
all hashtag ten days of getting back on
track
we'll make it
new year new bow demi lovato may have
opened her heart to a new man by the
looks of this pic MMA fighter gear made
bomba Vasconcelos posted of himself and
the confident singer cuddled up together
Marc Anthony's ex Shannon de Lima is
starting off 2017 on a happy note the
model shared this gorgeous shot of
herself on her 28th birthday rocking a
white bikini in the ocean captioning the
pic I'm starting off the new year on a
really happy note and with a big desire
to enjoy it and make the best out of it
[Music]
you